[Music]
hello and welcome to
night city wire episode five the show
from us at cd projekt red
where we talk about all things cyberpunk
2077
now we're going to start today's episode
with a new trailer that will take a
closer look at johnny silverhand
before we go behind the scenes with
keanu reeves
and have a chat to english adaptation
director boris
who will tell us exactly what it was
like to work with him
then we'll be exploring the original
score and talking about some of the
radio stations you might listen to while
driving around night city
before we take a look at the jolly
technology which is powering facial
animation in cyberpunk
and unveil a new my reward scheme which
anyone can take part in
no matter which platform you'll be
playing cyberpunk on
we'll then wrap up today's episode with
a brand new gameplay trailer
it's a busy episode and it will be our
final episode of night city wire before
the game launches
on december 10th so let's get going
[Applause]
[Music]
where did you even come from how are we
even talking
gotta get out of here i understand and
i'll kill
anyone who gets in my way
you are a dreaming bee those were
memories
you two are connected in a way i can't
make head or tail off
johnny silverhand real talk of the town
back in my day
he died like forever ago
you need to say there's an actual
terrorist in my head
right now he'd burn down half the city
just to pray he was right
and we're in the other half just for fun
what do you want from me
destroy arasaka i don't even know what
that means
do whatever it takes to stop him defeat
him
he already tried to take over your body
you know
just for a little while hear me [ __ ]
a bullet to the [ __ ] brain get out
just get the [ __ ] out
tell me how to get
you don't have much time left
[Applause]
you're a dick you know and you're a [ __ ]
maybe we'll fit together after all
sometimes we like to share things with
you and other times we like to keep
secrets and it can be worth it for that
big reveal pretty sure nobody was
expecting to see keanu reeves on stage
at e3
2019 so let's go behind the scenes to
see how keanu reeves bought
rocker boy johnny silverhand to life you
could say
it's breathtaking cyberpunk 2077
johnny silverhead i've had the
opportunity to do
voiceover a few times i've worked on a
cartoon
i had done some documentaries i've never
done this
much you know you don't gotta speak
out loud to talk to me and i've
processed some [ __ ]
changed my mind don't watch it dead
anymore
you know and got to play a character in
so many kind of different ways
because of different paths or threads or
choices so
you almost get to play one moment so you
have a decision when you take a bullet
with three different behavioral
attitudes
so that was fun you know he's uh
johnny's either a dick
or he's happy or he's trying to convince
know why
because you've always been a [ __ ]
[ __ ] carrie so it's been fun and that
was kind of what i was interested in
you know the different options that the
game could play
you know playing the same person but
with different versions of them
motion capture baby johnny silverhand uh
so
one of the first elements that i was
involved in with the game
was motion capture i've done a
fair bit of motion capture i did it with
uh in the matrix films
so to start doing motion capture for
johnny it was all very familiar to me
the only difference i think
technologically
was how close they were going to
real-time review
but creatively it was very familiar in
the sense of
starting a library of of gesture
and the toolbox let's say for
the animators to work with for the
character
[Music]
so you get to see johnny as the rock
star you know you hear about his
military past
you know and he's fighting for his
survival
so he's kind of got all these things
leading into the moment of this guy
it's really a kind of an interpretation
because i think there's a johnny silver
head
in all of us he's got a lot of energy
he's got a good sense of humor
if not a little dark at times
he's very passionate he cares you know
it's um
he's kind of naive but he's also super
experienced
in life he's got certainly an appetite
for life
no you're wrong he wants to change the
world
you know he has a cause that he wants to
fight against the corporate come on
don't tell me you're not interested he's
kind of looking for a different kind of
freedom
corpse have long controlled our lives
taken lots
and now they're after our souls least i
believed in something bigger
we saw i had cars
what cd projekt red has shared with me
and the way that they talk about the
game and what i've seen
is that it's got a lot of freedom
there's so many different paths that you
can play the game on
but it's not just quests
it's like who are you how do you want to
play the character
if i got a kill i'll kill if i need your
body i'll
[ __ ] take it you can go into action
you can go into mystery you can problem
solve in different ways
and where you go in this world there's
so much detail
there's so many different things that
you can go off into that are really
interesting
[Applause]
there's a real drama to the game and
emotional stakes to it and then there's
lighter sides to it and of course the
music
production design technologically how
cutting edge it is
i don't think there'll be a game that
looks like this yeah
it's intense
[Music]
everything i take the driver you get
inside
before we get into what it was like to
actually work with keanu reeves
was it always him that you imagined as
johnny silverhand was there anybody else
that you ever considered having for the
role
yeah holly it was a long arduous
extended
uh process to imagine what johnny
silverhand
is supposed to look like what he's
supposed to sound like what he's
supposed to
act like everybody and their
great-grandmother seemed to have an idea
and
the process actually involved a lot of
people game director
uh character artists writers marketing
staff
i could go on you know we cast a pretty
broad net initially
uh we considered actors we considered uh
enlisting
uh actual rock stars you know banned
front men to play the role
at one point we even toyed with the idea
of taking
and reviving uh a recently deceased
long-time luminary of the recording
industry
now some might say that it was a pipe
dream to assume that we could do that
technologically
or otherwise well i'll see you uh that
pipe dream and raise you another because
uh one could easily say that it was a
pipe dream to assume that we could
successfully pitch to and ultimately
enlist keanu reeves to play the role
now i'm sure this is on everybody's mind
right now but what was it actually like
to
work with keanu reeves because even he
said in the video
this was like nothing he'd ever done
before
a question uh that i'm sure uh anybody
who gets to
work with keanu has to answer and i get
where it comes from
keanu is a consummate professional when
he's at work
he's at work he's completely and utterly
focused
to that work he brings his talent he
brings his art his technical skill
and overwhelming charm and yes the scale
and the complexity were and are dazzling
non-linearities the variation in
attitude mood emotion that are required
to achieve them they can be difficult to
get your head around
and if you take all of johnny
silverhand's bits
uh you know his screen time it's like
doing the equivalent of
many many feature film roles put
together and we covered all that
in a handful of mocap sessions and
under two dozen vo recording sessions of
four to six hours each
and that took focus it took control it
took
dedication all of which uh keanu
provided in heaps
so tell us a little bit more about the
character of johnny silverhand and
why he's important to the story but also
why it's important to have him played by
like such a powerful personality
okay uh how do i do this without uh
spoiling too much uh for gamers
in the broadest sense i'd say johnny
silverhand
is a co-protagonist of the game rather
than
a sidekick i mean there are buddy bits
in the game
but uh in the end johnny has an agenda
and he pursues it and v has an agenda
and has to pursue that
and for to get things done v and johnny
have to work together things some of the
things they do rvs and
some of the things they do are johnny's
and some of them are important to
both of them that bonds
gamers i think to both characters
both characters agendas become equally
important
uh both characters continued existence
becomes equally important
for any a gamer or viewer or reader what
you have to
do is create that bond between them
and the protagonist or protagonist you
have to make
those characters understandable to them
likeable to them lovable to them
with that understanding even when they
do something
not entirely admirable or say something
reprehensible
you stay committed you stay involved you
stay bonded to them
and there's no denying casting a
powerful personality
somebody who exudes uh charm by the
truckload
helps to further all that so boris can
you tell us like what
does keanu bring to johnny silvland
what keanu brings to johnny silverhand
is nothing more and nothing less
than keanu i could parse that into a
string of adjectives
but i uh kind of think that would be
borderline insulting because it wouldn't
begin to do him justice
to anybody who's seen the applicable
movies
uh neo is keanu keanu is neo
john wick is keanu keanu is john wick
john constantine
johnny mnemonic jonathan harker johnny
utah they're all keanu
and to anyone who will play cyberpunk
2077
johnny silverhand will be keanu to my
mind at least
star power is a fact and a
an important factor for broad sections
of the audience out there
so can you give us more information
about the process of motion capture
right because we saw you
in the video you know doing some of it
but really how does it work
uh but i i wish i could holly but i'm
really no mocap expert and i can
i i can basically tell you what the day
looked like
what the process looked like to me to me
it was a fine day in l.a
and i put on a wonky looking bodysuit
with
globules all over it and i put on the
head cam
and then we proceeded to block and then
play out scenes between v and johnny
and we did it over and over and over
again as we did that i must have poked
johnny
uh in the chest hundreds of times uh and
i must have
uh yelled [ __ ] off at johnny 35 times
you know
and well i never
expected to be doing any of that no i
never imagined
i'd be doing any of that well boris
thank you
so much for joining us i your voice in
the studio is
quite iconic so whenever i talk to you i
feel like i'm in a trailer it's amazing
it's not all that
it's not all that holly thank you well
from uh
soviet era synthesizers to body heat
radio
it's time to explore the original score
and just some of the radio stations
you'll be listening to when you're
driving around night city
score is the main vessel of emotions in
both movies and video games and
cyberpunk 2077 is no different
it actually took us a long time to find
the right
color of the music
getting that sound together is almost as
important
as the actual look of the game itself
because music is really helping you
feel this emotional connection to the
game
[Music]
so one of the main ideas was to take the
cyberpunk genre out of the 80s
and give it a 90s flare we took elements
from
brave idm industrial and make them fit
our narrative purposes
we've decided that close to 100 of our
music would be
purely electronic that's why we tried to
stick to analog since as much as
possible so
it's got a warmth to it
i'm super proud of the team we've
managed to gather for this project
for me it was basically my own personal
aesthetic matching
the aesthetic of the game when i read
the brief i was like oh this is going to
be great i can be myself i can make
music and it comes from an honest place
i love the fact that the music in this
game is so
varied so we have some tracks that are
super dirty super heavy
and then we have some tracks that are
very beautiful and ambient i'm using all
kinds of different effects so
it's been great to be able to experiment
with the sound and the style
it's my first time actually doing any
drum tracking for a video game it's been
really exciting it's been a lot of fun
it's all about making you feel like a
perfect killing machine
because that's that's what you are
basically
well i can do that all day long so
you'll just you'll just you'll just have
to tell me what you like
what you don't like cool okay it's not
gonna sound like
one thing depending on what part of the
city you're in we basically
scored every quest pretty much with
custom
assets created specifically for that
quest we ended up having
over seven and a half hours of music in
cyberpunk working on cyberpunk has just
been insane
i can seriously say that i've never
worked with such a bunch of mad people
in my life and mad
brilliant
[Applause]
[Music]
the gear that we use comes out of
boutique shops or
their vintage synthesizers like this
polyvox
[Music]
[Applause]
i really hope all this effort put into
creating this score
pays off with satisfying and enjoyable
listening and gaming experience
hello night city what shaken night city
morning night city your man
stand here oh i love this town love it
like you might love a mother who popped
you out on the steps of an orphanage
once
and now stops you to ask if you got a
smoke fur
and now a shout out to all the lowlifes
over at the atlantis ladies and gents
here's that all-time classic
in night city
soundtrack is one of the key elements we
use to build
believable worlds we've invited artists
from around the world
incredible talents incredible musicians
to write and produce songs just for us
for this project
the soundtrack for cyberpunk is insane
so the soundtrack being
all the songs that they've got going on
whether it's on the radio or on the
background
all these just amazing bands we've got
over 150 custom
genre bending tracks all waiting for you
to discover them by yourselves
you know the reason i want to be a part
of cyberpunk is well basically i know
the witcher is
super sick and then i actually got to
play a preview of the game which was
[ __ ] incredible i've always wanted to
do something connected to a video game
so i was pretty excited when this came
in and it was like an instant yes
i was kind of imagining what it would be
like being a character in that game the
person that's the musician
in this world in this time has grew up
in that space this isn't just some fun
[ __ ] there's also an intellectual and
spiritual history
to this world that's been constructed
for you you know we want to provide you
with the soundtrack to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
like how could you not want to be a part
of that
for those of you who can't wait to hear
more from our composers
we're going to be releasing a special
six track cyberpunk
2077 ep featuring tracks from the game's
original score
on to streaming services for you to
enjoy for free
and they'll be live at the end of this
episode so you can give them a listen
later
in addition if you're planning on live
streaming cyberpunk or if you just want
to make videos
we want to introduce you to a new mode
that will allow you to disable
certain copyrighted tracks we know that
for content creators licensed music can
sometimes be problematic so with this
new mode
you'll be able to disable a small number
of selected tracks which
could cause some issues replacing them
with a different song
helping to avoid any problems if you're
going to be live streaming from console
this will start automatically
but you can toggle it on and off in the
options as needed
and for pc players you'll be able to
turn it on and off in the game option
don't forget as with all episodes of
night city wire if you're tuning in late
or if you just want to watch anything
again
we will be uploading everything to our
channels soon
now from polish to chinese when
cyberpunk launches it will have vo
in 10 different languages so we're going
to take a closer look at the
jali technology which is ensuring each
and every
one is as authentic as possible
so hi my name is sarah watling i am the
ceo
of jolly research in toronto ontario
in this video we're going to show you a
little bit about
jolly the software uh and jolly in
action within the world of cyberpunk
2077
rayfield's minecraft
jolly is a suite of tools and a suite of
services
uh that uh result in uh what we think
is the coolest and best uh and highest
quality facial performance on characters
oh is that supposed to sound familiar
it's automatically generated on a face
based on
audio dialogue audio speech from a voice
actor
slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well what jolly tries
to do is it tries to get to the root of
what is being expressed
in the vocal performance and put that on
a 3d character
that's rogue best fixer in all the night
city
there is just an incredible amount
of performance in this game
a procedural solution allows you to
animate
over and over and over again at
tremendous scale jolly is what powers
every single character
in the game of cyberpunk 2077 in
all of the languages that the game has
been localized
forward
[Music]
all you're doing is changing an
attribute for example speech style
if you want your character to to shout
instead of mumble
instead of issuing a set of commands
that redo the animation instead you
click
an attribute going from in this case
mumble to shout
but you walk you bleed but you walk
you bleed but you walk
you breathe if the lip sync is right you
don't notice
if the faces match and match the
performance you don't notice because
you're too busy paying attention how
awesome the game is
how much you care about these characters
how what what you're going to do
and that's what we want that to me is
that's that's the sizzle
don't you know you owe the sheriff a
word when you pay his town a visit
to tell him what's brought you here
maybe even over a cup of coffee
now we're excited to reveal digital and
in-game rewards for cyberpunk 2077.
it's our way of saying thank you for
your support
now every copy of the game comes with
digital downloadable goodies such as the
art book
the original score and a digital comic
all from the cyberpunk universe
but there's more you can also claim
in-game items for cyberpunk 2077
for example you could be rocking the
wolf school jacket
for simply connecting the game to your
gog account
and if you have other cd projekt red
games
such as the witcher or gwent you can get
even more
and it works both ways if you connect
the game to your gog account
you can also unlock special in-game
items for gwent
the witcher card game such as the
samurai inspired
card and coinback and the breathtaking
title now this new my reward program is
for
everybody no matter which platform
you're playing cyberpunk on
you'll be able to get your digital
goodies and in-game items
now this is just the beginning and
there'll be more items coming in the
future
and we'll have more information on my
rewards soon
as always don't forget that if you've
missed anything or if you just want to
watch again
we will be uploading everything to our
channels soon
so before we take a look at that new
gameplay trailer we just want to reveal
that a number of games media from all
over the world
have been playing cyberpunk 2077
and you'll be able to read their latest
impressions
when this episode of night city wire
finishes so you can go
and check them out so now let's wrap up
this episode and take a look
at that brand new gameplay trailer
they got unlocked on us engine's been
hit
get us out of here
at cd projekt red we dedicate ourselves
to telling immersive stories
yet with every new project we set out to
make our games bigger
more complex deeply engaging
come on v let's get you home cyberpunk
2077 marries
exploration of a vast open world with
kinetic combat
story changing player choices and robust
character development
all to bring you into our vision of the
dark future
if you ever feel like a city doesn't
give you a choice you either burn alive
in it
or you never existed at all the year
is 2077. an economic crisis
culminating in nuclear conflict has left
america in pieces
with most of the continent degenerating
into lawless war zones
people from all over have converged on
the already overcrowded night city
one of the world's last great
megalopolises
a hub amassing the best in resources and
know-how
and home to manufacturers of
cutting-edge technologies
night city continues to offer the
promise of a civilized future
what no no this isn't happening oh
but it is but in the city streets a
merciless struggle for power rages
gangs corporate agents hustlers
religious cultists
politicians and all manner of criminals
strive
to outplay one another ordinary people
get caught in the crossfire
looking for justice in night city i seek
revenge
much more feasible
in this world consumed by never-ending
conflict
sometimes only an outsider will get the
job done
elizabeth tells me you have answers for
us i'm all ears
and that's you an urban mercenary a
cyber-enhanced
gun for hire you seem to understand each
other
take this too as a mercenary you swear
no allegiance
you've chosen the outlaw life and trust
that your abilities will carry you up
night city's ruthless
underground social ladder
that's it right there to thrive as a
merc you need the right combination of
gear
skills and reputation dex had a load to
say about you
i hope he wasn't overselling with the
money you earn
you can turn yourself into a living
weapon buying guns and enhancements
as you roam the city's streets you gain
the experience you need to upgrade
abilities and acquire perks
combine the right skills and gear to
create a gunslinger within human
reflexes
a stealthy netrunner with command of all
surrounding tech
or practically anyone in between
[Music]
in cyberpunk 2077 you steal a prototype
biochip that can set you up for life
being filthy rich when a sealed
container is ruptured
the only way to prevent the biochip from
failing is to slot it into your head
it turns out it contains the digitized
soul of johnny silverhand
a dead rocker boy with violence on his
mind means to say there's an actual
terrorist in my head
right now he's out for revenge aims to
bring down the mega corp that made the
chip
do whatever it takes to stop him defeat
him
what is in your head can shift the
balance of power in night city
the high and mighty will do anything to
lay their hands on it
told you i'd end you someday
the choices you make will shape your
story and determine how events unfold
v you gotta take them down that's why
we're here but not everything in night
city is a matter of life and death
sometimes it's about style choosing your
look
you're right your pastime who's at your
side
choosing how you spend your dirty money
[Music]
welcome to the next generation of open
world adventure
immerse yourself in cyberpunk 2077
[Music]
you